We’re rolling?
Mhmm.
Okay.
Hi, I’m Corey D’Augustine.
I want to thank you for following along on
our MoMA IN THE STUDIO videos on YouTube or
by taking our free course on Coursera called
“In the Studio: Postwar Abstract Painting.”
Thanks, also, for all of your interesting
questions and comments.
In fact, we’ve gotten so many great ones
that we decided to do a live Q&A.
So you might want to drop by here on Wednesday,
that’s May 17th, at 3:30 when I’ll be
responding to some of the more interesting
ones that we’ve had so far.
But by all means, it’s not too late, so
please keep them coming.
So the way that they’re asking questions
is to log on and then to be typing before
or during the actual session?
Leave your questions in the comments section.
Yeah, in the comments below.
Okay.
Some of you have already asked some really
thought provoking questions on those videos.
Also feel free to do that below in the comments
section.
Some of you have been asking for new videos
about other artists.
Hope you might be interested to know that
we’re already working on the second section
of the de Kooning video.
But if there’s a specific artist or technique
or material or something like that that you
find really interesting, fascinating, and
you want to know more about, now’s the time
to let us know.
So for more details, check out the description
below, click the subscribe button, and I’ll
look forward to seeing you on Wednesday.
On this video there’s going to be a link
to that even before it’s live?
Yep.
Okay.